as reference breaking tonight an
apparent agreement on legislation to
address the coronavirus emergency the
House Speaker making that announcement
in a release trying to get some reaction
up on Capitol Hill congressional
correspondent Chad program live there
now good evening Chad that kind of
evolved we heard the president and the
rose-garden saying they're not doing
what needs to be done well the key here
was the fact that House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi and the secretary of the Treasury
Steve minuchin spoke 12 times today
including three times during the
president's press conference in the Rose
Garden that tells you despite what the
president was saying is that there was a
deal to be had House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi didn't think that the House of
Representatives could leave with this
still on the table
remember the Senate is out there were a
lot of Republicans in the House of
Representatives who were squeamish about
supporting something that the president
wasn't fully behind remember they've had
problems with the President on these
issues before Mitch McConnell the Senate
Majority Leader learned that the hard
way in 2018 when they had an agreement
they thought on the government funding
bill and then there was the government
shutdown even Kevin McCarthy of the
House Minority Leader I thought there
was an agreement earlier this week that
he negotiated with Bill Barr the
Attorney General on FISA and then that
has blown up in the Senate for the time
being so you know Republicans in the
House are very concerned about getting
this right I spoke with one senior
Republican who said that some of the
outstanding issues were just technical
this is why they thought they had an
agreement maybe 10 o'clock 11 o'clock
this morning and they might have this
bill on the House floor but this bill
will probably pass later tonight with an
amalgam of Democrats and Republicans
that what's key here Brett is we still
don't have the bill text House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi at one point this afternoon
seemed poised to go ahead and pass her
own bill without any Republican support
and basically say look you know we've
done our part the Senate it's up to you
president Trump it's up to you and if
you don't pass something we will see you
in November Brett right and Chad that's
important this Pelosi and heard letter
said she listed a few things including
secured paid emergency leave two weeks
have paid sick leave and up to three
months of paid family and medical leave
and
enhanced unemployment insurance what's
key here is that there were some
rumbling about other things being put in
this bill extraneous to the coronavirus
response and it may pass the House with
the majority being Democrats but it
still has to get through the Senate so
even if they made a deal it still has
another hurdle to go through that's
right and that's what Mitch McConnell
was waiting for just to see what the
street could bear in terms of the
traffic in the House of Representatives
now again the Senate unless they they do
something by extraordinary measures and
come back to session over the weekend
they're not going to tee things up until
about 5:30 in the Senate they're going
to address FISA then but when you talk
to other Senate Republicans Roy Blunt
Democrat Chris Coons from Delaware they
think they can pass a bill along the
lines of what the house will pass
tonight and send that to President Trump
they understand how grave this situation
is and they can't sit this one out and
very quickly I mean these bills
sometimes when there is an emergency and
it needs to happen fast and people don't
see what's in the bill that gets to
raise some eyebrows absolutely yeah and
that's why people were concerned they
want to see the details one draft of
this that we saw earlier was 106 pages
and keep in mind how tough it was to
pass tarp this was there the you know
the the Troubled Assets Relief Program
in response to the financial crisis in
2008 that bill failed in the House of
Representatives despite how grave and
dire the situation was here they're
going to pass a bill you know and again
keep in mind Bret that this is the easy
bill there's going to be a second tier
and a third tier bill which will be much
more complicated in the weeks and months
to come yeah and the president opening
for a payroll tax cut somewhere in there
Chadd program thank you very much for
the latest up on Capitol Hill